bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo qui per
scoprire perché ogni volta che faccio la
intro faccio sempre così non lo so manco
io ed è grave comunque ragazzi a parte
tutto siamo solo geometri dash che
sarebbe un videogame simile a the
impossible gente avevo fatto ragazzi
tipo in qualche mese fa mi era piaciuto
talmente tanto mi avete detto poi tutti
i fari ti prego fai a picche geometri
d'asti prego fai già ok dovrebbe essere
di magra vuoi vedere se abbastanza figo
posso persona rifarmi personaggi amico
mio sei la persona più [ __ ] che abbia
mai visto nella nostra piazza mii è vana
supposta questa direi che posso
chiamarlo gian francesco francesco va
bene così allora gianfrancesco direi che
essi si apre a la fiat ha già sa cosa
che puoi personalizzare il tipo stereo
madness
ma ci sono i primi chiarissimo noi
partiamo col primo che mi sta causando
eccoci qua dro partenza da dio
i ragazzi voglio vederci 6 gianfra ci
servono perfetto comunque ragazzi ha
proprio tutto giocatore l'impossible
game quando lo piccolo giocavo smesso
quando una voglia intera fare quindi
quando quando ero al cesso sì l'avevo
già detta sarov avrebbero praticamente
evalto sto facendo le madonne non hanno
mai giocato bellissima guarda lo
guardavo idee possibile
non ho mai giocato impossibile ho vinto
ho vinto ho vinto tutto non ha vinto un
caso che cosa sarà o mio dio ragazzi sto
cavalcando una supposta è normale mi
succede spesso quando vado in botta ok
ok
guardalo ancora lui incredibile non sto
facendo cos'è
gianfra ma che cazzo fai a numeri detto
che aveva la patente per le supposte ok
ragazzi incredibile non ho mai giocato
sto vincendo tutto
guarda lo fa donna madonna non basta se
vinco giro nudo per casa impossibile
caso basse
ragazzi io vi giorno non mai aperto sto
già non ci fosse che va dal impossibile
è impossibile
lo chef basta finisce il livello mica se
finisce il livello madonna madonna
madonna madonna mai mai mai mai gianfra
si no
non è finito
come no cosa dairago fatto troppo per
morire adesso non regga impossibile non
ci posso prendere mai che caccia la
primissima tutta volta che ci gioca ho
vinto
non ci posso credere che avete scritto
tipo tutti branzi il proprio dei
prossimo gli hi fi prova geometrica se
ti fa un culo così cosa non senti cosa
probabilmente era una specie di tutorial
perché non me la sto spiegando sta cosa
proprio va bene ma va dunque il prossimo
ragazzi di sicuro sarà una roba tipo
ecco bacon trek ma convinto che che ha
saltato solo a figo quando ci fossi così
saltano solo fantastico dopo la musica
porca [ __ ] dicevo la musica ragazzi è
bellissima e meglio di guadagno
impossible game addirittura ok allora
piano lo salta se madonna non capisco
più una sega calmiere è leggermente più
difficile perché c'è più merda di
[Musica]
madonna ma davvero nova franco bisogni
se mi stava emozionando cielo dritto
voglio vedere se è in grado niente
adesso non ce l'ho fatta non so come
arrivare fino qui ha perso non riesco a
far due metri ecco lo sapevo
e stato bello ragazzi concludo come
dicevo prima che diventi prezzo una
serie adesso sparò la figura di merda
totale che tipo la gloria di prima va
seppellita subito ti ammazzo la mamma
con la spazzola quindi non abituate via
st procura perché non manco per il cazzo
migliori coda di saltare non è figlio sa
cos'è che ti saltano solo è fantastico
però se do una mano a chi è meglio non
chiara gazione geometri desse è in grado
di tenere testa all'impossibile di the
impossible game ma credo che ci riesca
abbastanza bene perché c'è molta più
roba di the impossible di tipo ci sono
sì così che salta da solo e se fossi
volendo vi sono saltare tu e basta qua
invece fa cose in più con cap a parte
gli scherzi visto livello la porta di
quella merda sto livello hai fatto delle
cose che non so come il fatto ma non non
perderti or ok concentrato ti ammazzo la
famiglia ringrazia ricordo ragazzi per
avermi dentro che c'era anche il suo
metri da no se l'avessi saputo una
piccola era passato molto più tempo
successo non avete idea queste più
difficile di colori prima lo ammetto
però si può fare secondo me è una
femmina fini con centro ai così già a
fargli vedere chi comanda in questo
gioco
ok ma ma secondo me se gioca al cesso
sono più bravo non so perché lo sto
presentimento la concentrazione
bene benissimo e la madonna
caro con questa faccia che ti trovi
bella sorridente non puoi perdere capito
bisogna far capire a questo ragazzo chi
è che comanda
ok eccoci in casse gaza ragazzo
bellissimo
ok ok ok fin qua non c'era arrivato
credo così mi con doppio
sì perfetto sulla sul posto che era la
ragazzina subito sul posto è bellissima
ma non ho capito come si muore
non posso toccare a terra e come
facciamo a già 6 colpisca i costi o che
hai capito
madonna l'ho vista bruttissima sì sì già
sto facendo ragazzi calmi tutti
sì sì madonna sono troppo forte
troppa roba troppa roba dove obama le
sue meda dove sono le medaglie di obama
dove si minchia ragazze se riesco a
vincere anche questo base non ci posso
credere a caso sembra non sia quella che
metto nelle le giostre tipo non so come
ma porca [ __ ] 95 no 95 nota ammazzo la
mamma va bene 70 80 95 e proprio giada
stupro di criceto allora si va a fan
culo non potrò mai farlo più fino a quel
punto impossibile
devo saltare cribbio cambiamo c'è niente
niente se capisco che devo saltare
magari è meglio
bellissima la musica casa gliela voglio
come suoneria ma voglio anche sua mamma
come suoneria proprio che mi chiama
siete pronti per il singolo nuovo di
famiglia in uscita su i tunes free ma
che è bello giocare con questo quadrato
che salva gli ostacoli di lato
ma sto gioco poi chi se lo piglia se tu
perdi ti ammazzo la famiglia si è che
sto facendo capire che calmi calmi che
la supposta e la risposta la supposta si
si si
madonna madonna la pagina
[Musica]
madonna concluso salvato york a cercarmi
ragazzi che sto sudando freddo
sto suonando ghiaccioli praticamente un
acrobata che roba obama aspettami obama
aspettami obama dov'è la mia medaglia
voglio la mia medaglia fermi nazione
dove dove sono morto prima che non mi
ricordo più
potrei incazzare oltre inca potrei
uccidere qualcuno
e poi si tratta di un quadrato
sono morto allo stesso [ __ ] punto di
prima non è non è umanamente ma piace mi
hanno fatto fare un livello il primo che
ci ho messo cinque secondi e questo ci
mette 13 ore madre se non salta ho
giocato a the impossible game
niente devo saltare [ __ ] è bravo
infatti liukin noi prende pure per il
culo fantastico ragazze si ok affanculo
[ __ ] è caduto tutto è crollato il
mouse centesimo tenta 100 101 adesso
ovviamente tipo la carica la carica di
sta minkia io ringraziando i viola lo
sto giocando sul sul telefono sto gioco
che l'avrei l'ha già lanciato il tesoro
adesso non devo morire non devo morire
da morire mondo non mi ricordo dove è
qua e qua e qua
sì sì godo godo
[Musica]
se c'è back on track forti ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi 20 fottuti minuti quasi per fare
un livello 1 e ci sono ragazzi concluso
vile episodio anche se devo dire che a
parte il fatto che fa incazzare che
lamenta basta ma quello lo sapevo e fare
il più bello rispetto impossible gates
mia non me lo aspettavo neanche io
quindi lo continuerò nel prossimo
episodio forte mi sapere se volete che
io continui servizio è piaciuto ragazzi
trova subito lasciato un commento vi
piace anche face di facebook e come non
è da trattare iscrizione alle ore 16 20
cv diavolo prossimo video belle ragazze
[Applauso]
[Musica]
vai vai vai mai mai mai mai mai mai ma
che cazzo di livello ma no ma com è
riuscita a cadere uguale ma come è
possibile fermi un attimo che devo
provarci vai maledizione